اما المتحدث باسم الخارجيه الامريكيه في
دانت باتل فقد اوضح ان واشنطن تنسق مع
الشركاء الاقليميين والدوليين واصحاب
المصلحه من المدنيين السودانيين للمساعده
في انشاء لجنه للاشراف على مفاوضات وقف
الاعمال العدائيه بالسودان
بعد عمليه الاجلاء الناجحه لموظفي سفارتنا
بالخرطوم نعمل على خطين متوازيين الاول هو
مساعده الامريكيين في السودان والتنسيق مع
حلفائنا وشركائنا بشان الجهود المبذوله
لتامين مواطنيهم والخط الثاني يتمثل في
الضغط على الجيش السوداني وقوات الدعم
السريع لتنفيذ وقف اطلاق النار والالتزام
به بشكل كامل والسماح بوصول المساعدات
الانسانيه دون عوائق كما اننا ننسق مع
الشركاء الاقليميين والدوليين واصحاب
المصلحه من المدنيين السودانيين للمساعده
في شاي لجنه اشراف عدد المفاوضات وابرامي
وتنفيذ وقف دائم للاعمال العدائيه